Hey everybody, you're listening to Smart List, hosted by Jason Bateman, Will Arnett, and myself, Sean Hayes. I know, I wish my voice was more masculine too. This show is about learning through laughter in the brains of people around the world who are far smarter than us three idiots. And each week, one of us brings on a guest
大家好，欢迎收听由杰森·贝特曼、威尔·阿奈特和我肖恩·海斯主持的《Smart Less》。我知道，我也希望我的声音听起来更有男人味一点。这个节目的宗旨，是通过我们这三个白痴周围那些比我们聪明得多的人的大脑，在欢笑中学习。每周，我们中的一个人会带上一位嘉宾
who the other two don't know about. So with that, let's jump into the Smart List rocket ship and let's blast off into the universe together. Ooh, I think I just turned myself on. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
另外两个人事前都不知道是谁。废话少说，让我们跳上“Smart Less”号火箭，一起向宇宙发射吧。噢，我觉得自己好像被这火箭点燃了。Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Welcome back to Smart List. Yeah, welcome, it's nice to be here. Jason, do you have a recital today? Your hair is matted down.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. 欢迎回到《Smart Less》。耶，欢迎，很高兴来到这里。杰森，你今天是有什么朗诵会吗？你的头发都贴在头皮上了。
Dude, are you going to court? Have you got a... Did you catch a case? Oh, there it is, there it is, there it is. I was trying to pin my wing back. You know what I can do? I can put it on here. Let me help. Let me put on my workout headband. Hold on, this is great. You're going to love this.
老兄，你要去出庭吗？你是不是惹上什么……官司了？哦，有了，有了，有了。我刚才在试图把我的翅膀别回去。你知道我能做什么吗？我可以把它戴在这个上面。我来帮忙。让我戴上我的运动发带。等等，这太棒了。你会喜欢这个的。
Oh, God, you're going to love this. With the glasses and everything, it's kind of a really good look. Oh, look at that. Do you wear that working out for real? Yeah, I've got to keep my hair out of my face. Wait, you wear that headband to work out? Yeah. Well, I got blue.
哦，天哪，你绝对会喜欢这个。配上眼镜和这些行头，这造型简直绝了。哦，看那个。你锻炼时真的会戴这个吗？对啊，我得把头发从脸上弄开。等等，你锻炼时戴那个发带？对啊。我有蓝色的。
I got red. I've got white. Someone's American. I've also got some fuzzy Birkenstocks that I've been wearing around the house. What does red mean? Does red mean just handjobs? Yeah, open for H.J. It's just a more economical way to say it. Blue, you know, we keep it
我有红色的。我有白色的。这颜色很美国。我还带了几双毛茸茸的勃肯鞋，我一直在家里穿。红色是什么意思？红色是指单身打飞机吗？对，随时准备打飞机。这只是一种更委婉的说法。蓝色嘛，你知道的，
with the B's. That's for B.J. And then white means there's really no bad ideas. I got our listener logged off for quite a while ago. I know. We have today... Hang on, why don't we have your camera?
我们用字母B开头。那是口交的意思。然后白色意味着完全没有坏主意。我好久以前就把我们的听众给晾在一边了。我知道。我们今天……等等，为什么我们没有你的摄像头？
Well, because I have a special guest. Our special guest is en studio. Should I take off my headband? No, our guest really enjoys it. And they're going to tell you why in a second. But our guest... We have said this before, like,
哦，因为我有一位特别嘉宾。我们的特别嘉宾就在录音室里。我要把发带摘下来吗？不用，我们的嘉宾非常喜欢它。他们一会儿就会告诉你为什么。但我们的嘉宾……我们以前说过这样的话，比如，
no, this guest requires no introduction. But truly this is... But this one we need to carve out 20 minutes? We need a big introduction. Now, this person has done it all. And has been... Is a multi-academy award-nominated
不，这位嘉宾不需要介绍。但真的，这个……但这位我们需要腾出20分钟时间来？我们需要一个宏大的介绍。这位嘉宾可以说是无所不能。而且是一位多次获得奥斯卡金像奖提名的
actor. Has acted in over 4,000 films. All of which are the biggest films that I've ever been on the face of the planet. 4,000. Was also a cast member of Saturday Night Live. Has literally done everything
演员。参演过4000多部电影。所有这些电影都是我这辈子见过的最大的大片。4000部。也曾是《周六夜现场》的演员。 literalmente（字面意思上）做过
that show business has asked him to do. He has done it and given back to the world. Ladies and gentlemen, without further ado, your friend and mine, Mr. Robert Downey Jr. Oh, look at that. Son of a bitch.
演艺圈要求他做的一切事情。他都做到了，并且回馈了这个世界。女士们先生们，废话不多说，隆重请出你们和我的朋友，小罗伯特·唐尼先生。哦，看那。你个王八蛋。
Oh, R.G.J. It's on, like, kankidong. This is so... Don't remove the headband. It's very Charlie Sheen platoon send-up movie. Wow, it really is, actually.
哦，R.G.J.（小罗伯特·唐尼）。好戏开场了，像坎基东（kankidong）一样。这太……别摘下发带。这非常有查理·辛在电影《野战排》里的造型感。哇，还真的很像呢。
Bob, Robby. We met quite a while ago. Throbbing knob, if you don't mind. But then you have to remove the junior, because that would be embarrassing. So, I think that we met the very first time, was at the SAG Awards when you won over me
鲍勃，罗比。我们是很久以前认识的。如果你不介意的话，应该叫跳动的阴茎（Throbbing knob）。但那样的话你就得去掉“小（Junior）”字，因为那会很尴尬。所以，我想我们第一次见面是在演员工会奖上，当时你赢了我，
when you were on Ally McBeal. And we had to do Press in the Back and you were the kindest, nicest person I'd ever met that night. It was awesome. And I was like, I can't believe I'm meeting Robert Johnny Jr. It was so cool. And my next question is...
那时你在拍《甜心俏佳人》。我们得去后台接受采访，那天你是见过的最善良、最好的人。太棒了。当时我想，我简直不敢相信我正在见小罗伯特·唐尼。太酷了。我的下一个问题是……
Last question. No, I think that was it. I forgot that you done Ally McBeal. Right, you did a few... You ran for a while, right? I got out of the dirt. I went on to the show. The shunt.
最后一个问题。不，我想就是这样。我都忘了你演过《甜心俏佳人》。对，你演了几个……你演了一段时间，对吧？我从烂泥里爬出来了。我去了那个节目。那个垫场。
I remembered an old pager number and I got kicked off the show. I love that journey. Oh, the pager days. And then you just got to go down to a payphone and wait for them to call and make sure no one takes the payphone. There's only one there.
我想起了一个旧的寻呼机号码，然后我就被节目开除了。我喜欢这段经历。哦，寻呼机的日子。然后你得去公用电话亭，等着他们回电，还要确保没人占了那个电话亭。那里只有一个电话。
Buddy, can you step back? I'm expecting a call. There's a lot of stress. I don't know what version of Raleigh Studios Manhattan Beach you were at, but we had dressing rooms with landlines. Oh, yeah. No, I was at the Hilton
老兄，你能退后点吗？我在等一个电话。压力太大了。我不知道你在曼哈顿海滩的罗利制片厂哪个版本，但我们的化妆间里有座机。哦， yeah。不，我在希尔顿酒店，
at the 405 in Sunset. In the revolving bar. Yeah. How is this phone not getting tied up in its own cords when this bar has turned 18 times since I paged him back?
在405公路和日落大道的交汇处。在旋转酒吧里。对啊。自从我回了呼机后，这酒吧已经转了18圈了，这电话线怎么还没缠死？
How long has it been? It's been 45 Getty Centers. That's how long it's been. Robert, I'm taking quite a bit of supplements each day. Amanda, my wife, has got me... for them to kick in. She's got a bunch of
过去多久了？已经过去45个盖蒂中心了。时间就是这么久。罗伯特，我每天都在吃相当多的补剂。我老婆阿曼达让我……为了让这些补剂起效。她有一群
people that she trusts, defers to, respects, that understand medicine, Western and Eastern. And I am the proud recipient of some of that thing. But I am swallowing about 30 supplements a day as a result.
她信任的、推崇的、尊重的、懂得东方和西方医学的人。而我很荣幸地成为其中一些东西的受益者。但因此我每天要吞下大约30种补剂。
You're about at that with me, aren't you? I've seen your kit. Are you at 30? It varies, but look, I know Amanda, and I know that whole circle of alternative medicine. You might be responsible for a couple
你跟我差不多吧，对不对？我见过你的药盒。你也是30种吗？这因人而异，不过听着，我认识阿曼达，我也知道那个替代医学的圈子。你可能得为我不得不听取的其中好几个医生负点责任。伸出手接受就好了。
of these doctors that I'm having to listen to. Just put your hand out and take it. Particularly nowadays, I mean, you know, you go get blood work, and they say, oh, your iron's a little... this or that. And there's all these new things that the deeper you go into looking at a panel, the longer you can
特别是现在，你知道的，你去验血，他们会说，哦，你的铁有点……这样或那样。随着你对验血报告的研究越来越深入，有这么多新方法能让你
sustain. When your doctor checks your blood, especially at your iron man. I usually sniff after a real powerful joke. Is that what you do? Is that your trademark? If you were a recording artist, would you be looking at your albumin?
维持得更久。当你的医生检查你的血液时，尤其是针对你的钢铁侠。我通常会在一个非常强有力的笑话后吸一下鼻子。你也是这样吗？这是你的招牌动作吗？如果你是个录音艺术家，你会盯着你的白蛋白看吗？
Nice. Now, do you feel... I'm still on the supplement thing. I don't feel bad, but I don't know if I feel great because I don't... I haven't knock wood. I haven't felt bad for
不错。现在，你觉得……我还在说补剂的事。我感觉并不差，但我不知道我是否感觉很好，因为我……我没有敲木头（求好运）。我很久没
a long time. I can't attribute this to the supplements. I don't know whether it's just because it's that or because I'm not eating a cheeseburger every day or I'm no longer drinking. Are you still going the vegan, Bayman? No, I tried to... I did that to drop the cholesterol and I did it for
感觉不舒服了。我不能把这归功于补剂。我不知道这是因为这个原因，还是因为我不再每天吃汉堡了，或者我不再喝酒了。贝特曼，你还在坚持纯素食吗？没有，我试过……我这么做是为了降胆固醇，我坚持了
six months and I dropped one point. You had a scary... you've got a very high cholesterol. I know that because we share the same doctor and she gives me results. I hope you're cool with that. But my question, Robert, is do you... So there's a question in here.
六个月，结果只降了一点。你曾有过令人担忧的……你的胆固醇非常高。我知道这一点，因为我们共用同一个医生，她把结果告诉了我。希望你对此不介意。但我的问题是，罗伯特，你……所以这里有个问题。
I'm famous for all that. So you believe in all this stuff. You're still taking them or are you just kind of like, I don't know if they're working or not. All I know is I'm not dead yet, so why screw with it? I'll just keep doing what I'm doing. Well, I mean, look, some of it is pretty irrefutable.
我因所有这些而出名。所以你相信这一切。你还在吃它们，还是说你只是觉得，我不知道它们到底有没有用？我只知道我还没死，所以干嘛跟它过不去？我还是继续做我正在做的事吧。好吧，听着，其中有些东西确实是无可辩驳的。
You can go by how you feel by the recommendations of people that are smarter than you. But again, these are, you know, desperate times, desperate measures. It's very odd. Tell me if you can relate to this since March and we've done everything we're supposed to do
你可以根据自己的感觉以及比你更聪明的人的建议来判断。但话又说回来，这些都是，你知道的，非常时期，非常手段。这真的很奇怪。如果你能对这一点感同身受的话，请告诉我：自从三月以来，我们做了所有我们该做的事，
and I've lost a friend to COVID and the folks we know obviously have gotten it and it's a big deal. But it's also odd how few other things have come up within my circle of friends or people I know since because the threat has been
我有一个朋友因新冠去世了，我们认识的人显然也感染过，这是一件大事。但同样奇怪的是，自那以后，我的朋友圈或我认识的人中间，极少出现其他什么病症，因为这种威胁已经被
so homogenized and made into this one thing that I don't usually you get a summer cold. Right. But strangely, at least in the areas where people are following all the guidelines and the protocols, all that sort of stuff is just down. Just because people aren't interacting
极度同质化了，变成了这么单一的一件事，以至于——你通常会得夏季感冒。没错。但奇怪的是，至少在人们遵守所有指导方针和协议的地区，所有这些病症都减少了。仅仅是因为人们没有相互
with each other, do you think? Probably. And then you have to go to what's the real element here is an unprecedented psychological shift and having done actual time there's something very interesting about having your movement
接触，你觉得呢？很可能是这样。然后你不得不思考，这里真正的要素是一次前所未有的心理转变，而真正坐过牢的人会觉得，限制你的行动是一件非常有趣的事，
limited and all that and for kids and all that stuff and stuff. So I think a lot of it is you know, there's an immunological response to these crazy circumstances. Yeah, it's funny to bring that up like the being confined and talking about doing actual time
诸如此类，对孩子们也是如此，等等。所以我认为很大程度上，你知道的，这是对这些疯狂环境的一种免疫反应。对，提起这个真有趣，比如被禁足，谈论真正的坐牢，
people talk about quarantine when you hear people going like, oh my God, I've been stuck in my beautiful house for the last six months. Are you like, dude? Yeah. Shut the hell up. No, I'm not. Because every what everyone's going through is what they're going through and it's specific to them and it is a big deal. How long were you
人们谈论隔离时，当你听到有人说，天哪，我过去六个月一直被困在我美丽的家里。你会不会想说，老兄？对啊。闭上你的臭嘴。不，我不会。因为每个人经历的都是他们自己正在经历的事，这对他们来说是具体的，而且是一件大事。你被关了
were you given time to think about it all? How much time did you spend being quiet in a room? How long were you incarcerated? I think he's what he's trying to say. Yeah, I mean, just ask the question. Yeah, how long were you locked up? You're still mumbling. That was that lascivious tone.
你有被给予时间去思考这一切吗？你在一个房间里保持安静度过了多少时间？你被监禁了多久？我想他这是在试图说……对啊，我的意思是，直接问问题呗。对啊，你被关了多久？你还在嘟囔。那种语气真淫荡。
My shame, mumble. That sounded like Dungeon 4 play to me. How long do you want to be locked up? I did 12 days once, four months, 13 days, a second time, and then something like three years or so.
我的羞耻感，嘟囔。听起来像是地牢里的前戏。你想被关多久？我曾经蹲过12天，四个月，第二次是13天，然后大概是三年左右。
I forget. The last time it didn't matter because it was state time. What does that mean? It just means you're not in county. You're not in some awful spot. You're just in a actual prison where you have significantly more freedom. For how long?
我忘了。最后一次无所谓了，因为那是州监（state time）。那是什么意思？那只是意味着你不在郡看守所。你不是在某个糟糕的地方。你只是在一个真正的监狱里，在那里你有明显更多的自由。多长时间？
I don't know. I think, well, I know that Judge Myra God bless him through the book, the gavel, his wig, and the bench at me. His wig. So I think I had a three-year suspended sentence and but then I appealed it. It turned out he had over sentenced me.
我不知道。我想，好吧，我知道迈拉法官——上帝保佑他——把法书、法槌、假发和审判席全都朝我砸了过来。他的假发。所以我想我被判了三年缓刑，但后来我上诉了。结果证明他判得过重了。
And I don't blame him for it. I had done the same thing. But you weren't three years in a jail cell, were you? I think it was 26 months or something like that. Wow. Wow. See, I've done things in my life not to avoid prison, but I'm just fingers crossed. I'm like, oh, God, that'd be so hot.
我并不怪他。我自己也会这么做。但你并不是在监狱单间里呆了三年，对吧？我想大概是26个月左右吧。哇。哇。看吧，我这辈子做某些事不是为了逃避监狱，但我只是祈祷。我就想，天哪，那一定很刺激。
Yeah. So hot. Just for a weekend. I would imagine knowing you as I do, I'll bet you can probably say that you grew mentally and spiritually to the positive in a way
对啊，太刺激了。哪怕就一个周末。我想像我一样了解你的话，我敢打赌你大概会说，你在精神和心灵上得到了积极的成长，这种成长
that you would never take back. You've probably better now than you ever were because of that focusing of the mind during all that isolation, yes? Well, first of all, I probably deserved it. So that helps. Second of all,
是你绝不会收回的。由于在所有这些隔离期间进行了心智的集中，你现在可能比以往任何时候都更好，对吗？嗯，首先，我可能罪有应得。所以这有帮助。其次，
it's very monastic and rather dangerous and isolating. It's awful. It's traumatic. But again, for someone who's never been told to stay at home and drop ties with their family
这非常像僧侣的生活，而且相当危险和孤立。这太糟糕了。这是创伤性的。但话又说回来，对于一个从未被告知要待在家里、切断与家人的联系、
and miss birthdays and funerals and weddings and not see the birth of your sister's baby or whatever, it's, you know, it didn't bother me. Sorry. Well, that's what I'm trying to gently ask is that
错过生日、葬礼和婚礼、看不到你外甥出生等等的人来说，你知道的，这并没有困扰我。抱歉。好吧，我其实是想委婉地问，
you probably found the growth in it to the extent that there is some of that isolation, getting back to what Will was talking about all this quarantine thing. We're reading articles. We're hearing things about how people are finding the plus and the minus
你可能从中找到了某种成长，在某种程度上，存在着某种隔离，就像威尔刚才一直在谈论的所有这种隔离的事情一样。我们在阅读文章。我们听到一些关于人们如何在隔离中发现积极和消极面的人，
of isolation and it is a choice, I would imagine. What you went through was something completely different and quite a bit more severe, obviously. And public. Yeah, but I would imagine you found some real growth during the quiet time just sitting there thinking
我想这是一种选择。你经历的完全是另一回事，而且显然要严重得多。而且是公开的。对，但我猜你在坐在那里无所事事、没有任何选择、无法分心的安静时间里，确实找到了一些真正的成长。
with no choices, no ability to distract. Yeah, I think I've said this before but here's a crazy thing too. If you've had a trippy life and I think all of us can agree that just being in the entertainment field is, you know, we know the psychological breakdown of
对，我想我以前说过这个，但这里有一件疯狂的事。如果你经历过一段光怪陆离的人生，我想我们都会同意，仅仅身处娱乐圈就已经——你知道我们了解像我们这样的人的心理崩溃。
folks like us. Something about having a cell door closed behind you. Wow. This is when I was in Twin Towers in the glamour slammer. You will never be safer than you are
当一扇牢门在你身后关上的时候……哇。这是我在双子塔（Twin Towers）的“魅力大牢（glamour slammer）”的时候。你永远不会比被惩教人员或警长
when a correctional officer or the sheriffs lock you down in that room. As long as you trust your celly you will never be safer than that because until the morning when they pop them open. Yeah. Wow. One time,
锁在那间屋子里时更安全。只要你信任你的狱友，你就永远不会比这更安全，直到早晨他们打开门的那一刻。哇。有一次，
I remember Sean, this is a while ago you told me this and I think you're over it now but I remember you telling me that one time at the Four Seasons they fucked up your room and they put you next to the elevator. Yeah, and I thank you for bringing that up Will. Yeah. A lot of people think my pain isn't really there. Sure.
我记得肖恩，很久以前你跟我说过这个，我想你现在已经不在乎了，但我记得你告诉过我，有一次在四季酒店，他们把你的房间搞砸了，把你安排在电梯旁边。对，谢谢你提起这个，威尔。对。很多人觉得我的痛苦不是真的。当然。
So I went, I didn't walk, I marched to that front desk and I said, you weren't even sure if you could hear the ding or the phantom ding. Yeah, do you hear that ding because it's in my head. It's loud enough in my head. It must be in yours by now. Knowing it was there. Because you know what you're going to hear in the morning, sir?
所以我去了，我不是走过去的，我是大步走到前台，我说，你甚至都不确定自己能不能听到那个“叮”声或者幻听的“叮”声。对，你听到那个“叮”声了吗，因为它在我的脑子里。在我脑子里已经够响了。现在肯定也在你脑子里了。明知它就在那里。
And the repeated trauma too because I heard they'd given you a 2pm check-in but housekeeping hadn't really gotten down into the dude, don't do this to him. I'm so glad I didn't bring the story up. Thank you. No, wait, I want to say that because I come from a family of
因为你知道早上你会听到什么，先生？还有反复的创伤，因为我听说他们原本给了你下午2点入住的权限，但客房服务还没来得及搞定——老兄，别这样对。我真高兴我没提起这个故事。谢谢。不，等等，我想说的是，因为我来自一个有
several addicts and I always and I've asked, I've had this conversation with Will several times too. I always find I'm fascinated with how the brain works about that and so I always ask people like yourselves if I had a drink in front of you or was doing a line
好几个瘾君子的家庭，我总是——而且我也问过，我和威尔也进行过好几次这样的对话——我总是发现我对大脑如何运作这件事很着迷，所以我总是问像你们这样的人：如果我把一杯酒放在你面前，或者在你面前摆上一道
of Coke, which I've never done or smoked a pot or whatever it is in front of you now at this stage after all you've been through is that a trigger for you? Are you enough? Have you gotten beyond the fact that actually not only is it not a trigger, I see that and I'm like, I really don't want anything to do with that. Or is there
可卡因——我从没吸过——或者抽大麻，或者在你经历了这一切的现阶段，无论它是什么，在你面前出现时，这会成为你的诱因吗？你已经释怀了吗？你是不是已经超越了那种状态：事实上，它不仅不是诱因，我看到它时反而会想，我真的不想和它有任何瓜葛。还是说
still a part of you that likes that or wants that? It's been long enough where to me like we had some guests over and it was my buddy's 50th birthday and before that there was some guests visiting or have a couple kids and one of them had to go out of town. I could tell I was just like
你内心深处仍然有一部分喜欢它或渴望它？时间已经够久了，对我来说，就像我们之前接待了一些客人，那是我的好哥们50岁生日，在那之前有一些客人来访，或者家里有几个孩子，其中一个得出门一趟。我能感觉到我当时就像是，
all right, get two bottles of white get two bottles of red, get one bottle of rosé get two bottles of Vouv Clicquot and the Grand Dom. I know and take me back to Paris the way you just said that I still know the experience the same way that if you're
好吧，拿两瓶白葡萄酒，拿两瓶红葡萄酒，拿一瓶桃红葡萄酒，拿两瓶凯歌香槟和唐培里侬。我知道，你刚才说这话的语气把我带回了巴黎，我依然用同样的方式了解这种体验：如果你对某种药物过敏，但你知道它能为别人缓解痛苦，你会说，你知道吗，我现在手里有点这东西。
allergic to a medication but you know that it would take the edge off for someone else you would say you know what I have some of that now. And you want that for someone else in a way. That's the caretaker in you. You're a very good caretaker to say. So that I was there for one of those and
而且你在某种程度上也希望别人能拥有它。那是你体内的照顾者本能。你是一个非常善良的照顾者。所以我也在现场经历了其中一次，
you were offering somebody wine and then you told you're like, come with me. And I went down with you to get the bottle of wine and then you held it for half the trip upstairs. And then I handed it like a relay race. How long was that? Four days ago. Four days ago. Oh wow. By the way that's just still an experiment because nothing
你当时在给某人提供葡萄酒，然后你告诉我，跟我来。我和你一起下去拿那瓶葡萄酒，然后你在上楼的路上拿了一半的时间。接着我像接力赛一样把它递过去。那是多久以前的事？四天前。四天前。哦，哇。顺便说一句，这依然是一个实验，因为当事情发生时，什么也不会
happens when it happens right. You know you let's say you get insulted and two weeks later listen to the podcast really two weeks later like we were saying that's when you have to come back and you're really ready to go confront that person. Right because you've had time. Yeah. Anyway
立刻发生，对吧。你知道的，假设你被羞辱了，两周后——听这个播客真的就像两周后一样——就像我们刚才说的，那时你才必须回来，你才真正准备好去面对那个人。对，因为你有了时间。不管怎样，
we know what to do and I got your I got your boy here and we keep an eye on each other in this great community. Because also the other thing that's fascinating in my brain too is whatever part of the brain that is wired to addiction once you've kind of curbed that or even if you haven't and then
我们知道该怎么做，我把你的好兄弟带来了，在这个伟大的社区里我们互相照应。因为在我的大脑中同样迷人的另一件事是，无论大脑中哪一部分连线到成瘾上，一旦你某种程度上抑制住了它——或者即使你没有抑制住，然后
fame hits like for example you were always famous you were always working you were always in the public eye but then when this marvel thing happened and now you're literally a viable gigantic global product now in the world does that because they say fame can be
名气袭来——比如，你一直很有名，你一直在工作，你一直活在公众的视线中，但当这个漫威的事情发生时，现在你字面意义上成了世界上一个庞大巨大的全球化商业产品，这会不会——因为他们说名气也可以
a drug too does that trigger anything or does that replace it and you have to be careful about that. Triggers all the character defects but you don't have to worry about that until you're at that part of your recovery. To me more than anything I was just like I had something that I was like wow
是一种毒瘾——这会触发什么吗？或者它会取代毒瘾，你必须对此保持警惕？会触发所有的性格缺陷，但你直到进入恢复期的那个阶段才需要担心这个。对我来说，比起别的，我更像是：我有过某种经历，当时我想，哇，
leave it to me to fuck this up. And so I knew my own inclinations. I was going to say the other thing is you brought up and Robert you were just alluding to it which is and you hear this a lot in AA
把这事搞砸这种事也就只有我能干得出来了。所以我了解自己的倾向。我本来想说的是，另一件事你提到了，罗伯特你刚才也暗示了，那就是——你在戒酒匿名互助会（AA）和康复中心经常能听到这个——
and in recovery that community is the opposite of addiction right? Right. And that's what's so important and yeah so you know we joke about having the hot potato bottle of wine but to answer your question from my side if I'm there I don't
社区就是成瘾的对立面，对吧？没错。这就是为什么它如此重要，所以，你知道的，我们开玩笑说拿着那瓶烫手的葡萄酒，但要回答你刚才的问题，如果我在场，我并
feel I don't feel threatened I don't feel like I'm just going to rip the bottle off the top of the bottle and I'm going to guzzle it under the table but we can't be too sure. We can't be too sure and there's still enough time left in the day to do it but I know that especially if I'm there and he's there that I'm really good
不觉得受威胁，我不觉得自己会直接扯掉瓶盖然后一饮而尽，但我们不能百分之百确定。我们不能百分之百确定，而且一天之中还有足够的时间去这么做，但我知道，特别是如果我在场而他在场，我真的很好；
and if it's Robert or if it's one of my other friends and he's got a million people in his life and I have a million people in my life that's the key. And if I'm there with a red headband you know that the rest of the day is going to be taken care of. The rest of the day is a party. That means that it's Ozark season 4
如果换作罗伯特，或者我的其他朋友，他的人生中有成百上千的人，我的人生中也有成百上千的人，这才是关键。如果我和他一起戴着红色发带，你知道这一天的剩下时间都会被安排得妥妥当当。剩下的时间就是一场派对。这意味着那是《黑钱胜地》第四季，
we're on the front of the boat I think it should be you and a headband dancing. Slow dance for opening credits. Now Robert you're too humble to be comfortable with this question but were you aware was it a conscious shift in your incredible inner power to shift
我们在船头，我觉得应该由你戴着发带跳舞。片头曲时的慢舞。现在，罗伯特，你太谦虚了，无法坦然面对这个问题，但你是否意识到——这是你不可思议的内在力量的一次有意识的转变——把
your addiction to having fun your hedonistic instincts and drive those into work, into family, into friends, into the support work you do with other buddies that struggle I mean it is incredible
你对成瘾的渴望转化为寻求快乐、将你享乐主义的本能和驱动力投入到工作中、家庭中、朋友中，以及你为其他苦苦挣扎的兄弟们所做的支持工作里？我的经历简直不可思议，
what you have done on the backside of what you have been through and you have doubled all of your success, experience, influence affect over the people that you care about and an industry. Was it conscious say
你在经历了这一切之后取得了翻天覆地的成就，你将你所有的成功、经验、影响力和对身边人及整个行业的影响力翻了一番。当时是有意识地
okay I know I got an engine here I should point it a more responsible way or you just like oh gosh look this is happening again for me I'm not going to screw it up this time and it was less proactive and just kind of playing defense sometimes
对自己说“好吧，我知道我体内有一个引擎，我应该把它指向一个更负责任的方向”，还是你只是觉得“哦天哪，看吧，这事儿又发生在我身上了，我这次绝不能把它搞砸”，并且防守多于主动，有时候
you know that whatever the usual mosh pit if you could slow down the response that would be great to match his slow the question I want Will to interpret this
你知道的，无论通常是怎样的乱局，如果你能放慢反应速度那就太好了，好跟上他——放慢问题，我想让威尔用他
his own way while he's riding the mic like he's about to gobble this knob Oh, Ridley starts grabbing the bottom of it Sluller, half the time whatever all that that maelstrom of all my rationalizations
自己的方式来解读，当他骑着麦克风就像要吞下这个阴茎一样。哦，里德利开始抓它的底部了。更慢一点，大半时间无论那所有一切——我所有的合理化解释
and all that sometimes it just goes away and you see something clearly you have a moment of clarity if you're lucky enough to get that you can squander it and I've done that a bunch too sometimes you get it and you also realize that you're redlining the hubcaps are off and you are not even going to forget
以及所有那些东西，有时它只是消失了，你看清了某些东西，你拥有了一个清醒的时刻。如果你足够幸运能得到它，你完全可以挥霍它，我也这么挥霍过好几次。有时你得到了它，你也意识到你正在红线超转（redlining）、轮毂盖都飞了，你甚至
make it to any destination you're not even going to make to the next filling station and you're going to be stuck and I think also part of it was a function of age because I wasn't a kid anymore I was in my early 40s and I was like oh my god this again but I really wanted
都去不了任何目的地，你甚至连下一个加油站都开不到，你就要抛锚了。而且我想这也是年龄增长的一个功能，因为我不再是个孩子了，我当时四十出头，我想“哦天哪，又来这一套”，但我真的很想
all that dumb stuff that let's just face it we all think we want and then we get it and we go down the K hole of realizing that it was never really that it was just about feeling you know useful and occupied and wanting to maybe have a leadership position just because
得到所有那些愚蠢的东西——让我们面对现实吧，我们都以为自己想要这些，然后我们得到了，接着我们就陷入了K粉式的幻觉，意识到那其实从来都不是为了那些，那只是为了感觉
if you're in a leadership position you're more obliged to not drop the ball Yeah, well that I love that I was going to say Jason that you know it's funny that you asked that question because I will say that as your friend I've noticed that you have
自己有用、有事可做，并且可能想拥有一个领导地位，仅仅是因为如果你处于领导地位，你就更有义务不掉链子。对，我喜欢这个。我本想说的是，杰森，你知道的，你问这个问题很有意思，因为我要说的是，作为你的朋友，我注意到你已经
turned a lot of energy and stuff that you otherwise used to pour into um late night activity and you channeled that you made a decision and we've talked about it and I've seen you make that decision you've poured it into your life and your kids
把大量的精力和那些你以前倾注在深夜活动中的东西转化了，你做出了一个决定——我们谈论过这个，我也亲眼看到你做出了这个决定——你把它倾注到了你的生活、你的孩子、
into your home and into your work and you actually made a conscious decision am I right about that uh yes but well as you say that I start thinking about oh my god I'm so lucky that I've got an opportunity to work in this business because if I didn't
你的家庭和你的工作中，你实际上做出了一个有意识的决定，我说的对吗？呃，是的，但威尔，当你这么说的时候，我开始想，天哪，我是多么幸运，我有机会在这个行业里工作，因为如果我没有这份工作，
what would I do with all that ambition what would I do with all of that I want to do the right thing now with all of this energy and all of this sort of drive I worry about maybe that's why I work so hard and try to diversify I don't want that
我该拿我所有的雄心怎么办？我该拿我所有的——我现在想用所有的精力和所有的这种驱动力去做正确的事。我担心，也许这就是为什么我工作得这么努力并且试图多元化，我不想让
that portal to go away but you know one of the things is it and you guys both kind of alluded to it and one of the great things about Downey is that he does seem very calm and he does have very for a guy who's been through a lot he has a lot of sage calm maybe not but he's got a lot of sage words for
那个出口消失。但你知道，其中有一件事是——你们两个都暗示过了——唐尼最棒的一点在于，他看起来确实非常冷静，而且对于一个经历过很多事情的人来说，他有很多明智的冷静——也许不是，但他有很多明智的话要说。
but the other the flip side is that he is constantly of service and that's a big thing and you know I see it and he's such a great example I've told him too I'm amazed and in awe of how much of service he is to other people in and out of whatever
但另一面是，他一直在为他人服务，这是一件大事，你知道的，我看到了，他是一个多么好的榜样。我也对他说过，我对他在无论什么情况下为他人服务的程度感到惊叹和敬畏。
he's constantly of service in his life and I think that that removing that sort of constantly worrying about the sense of self allows you that room to grow would you agree that you don't have to be as aware or thinking about what am I going to do yeah it's just that Jedi
他在生活中一直在为他人服务，我认为那种不再不断担心自我意识的事情，能给你留下成长的空间。你同意吗？你不必那么有意识地去想“我要做什么？”对，这只是一种对自我为了最高利益而施展的绝地
mind trick played on self for the highest good and you know let's let's not split hairs here Bateman you and I should have both been Hollywood casualties we were raised to go oh my god the shadow of our dad's the thing that that the pressure
心灵把戏。而且，你知道的，贝特曼，我们别在这里抠字眼了，你和我本都该成为好莱坞的牺牲品。我们从小就被灌输“哦天哪，父亲的阴影，这种压力
is killing me oh now I've got it now I feel empty you know what let's let's make a mockery of this opportunity I appreciate being coupled with you but you my friend have have gone past the most incredible self-imposed adversity
快把我逼疯了，哦，现在我拥有了，现在我感到空虚”。你知道吗，让我们把这个机会当成一个笑话来嘲弄吧。我很感激能与你并列，但我的朋友，你已经超越了
it's just going to make for an incredible book if you ever put it down one day did you guys ever cross paths when you were younger we did I remember being at a house once that you rolled in for just sort of a drive-by and this is going to be great
最不可思议的自我强加的逆境。如果你有一天把它写下来，这绝对能写成一本不可思议的书。你们年轻时有过交集吗？我们有过。我记得有一次在某个房子里，你只是顺路开车过来待了一下，这太棒了。
we lost you to the bathroom were you with Leif no Leif was not there but I do remember you coming in and I was excited because I thought oh well here we go I get to get my party on but you went into the bathroom and then came out
我们把你弄丢在洗手间了。你当时和利夫（Leif）在一起吗？不，利夫不在那儿。但我确实记得你进来过，我当时很兴奋，因为我想，哦，好吧，我们要开始了，我可以开始狂欢了。但你走进了洗手间，然后出来，
and then you were off to the next spot and I was like ah I missed that I wonder if you left anything behind the toilet for me you know one of my moves used to be a lot of this too is called the old living amends like some of this I feel it's important to host your life the people you love
接着你就去了下一个地方，当时我想，啊，我错过了。我一直在想你有没有在马桶后面给我留下什么东西。你知道的，我以前的拿手好戏之一就是很多这样的事，这被称为“向过去的生活致歉（living amends）”。其中有些我觉得很重要，那就是招待你的生活、你爱的人、
and this and that you're meant to take care of them and make sure their needs are met and it's compensatory I used to be known as the guy who would go into my girlfriend's roommate's bathroom I'm going to piss in this potpourri
以及诸如此类的事。你的用意是照顾好他们并确保他们的需求得到满足，这是一种补偿行为。我以前被称为那种会走进女朋友的室友的洗手间、
I wonder how long it'll take him to realize what I've done dig here just to be funny or just because just because it was reverent and weird but usually there would have been a little tinge of resentment like you know Amber Shidness said that to me
要在盆景 potpourri（香碎花）里撒尿的人。我想她得花多长时间才能意识到我干了什么，就在这里挖个洞，只是为了好玩，或者仅仅因为——仅仅是因为这种行为既亵渎神明又古怪，但通常会带有一点点怨恨，就像你觉得“安珀·希德斯（Amber Shidness）对我说过那样的话，
I wonder I wonder how long until this little basket of dried flowers is going to smell like a fucking Panthers dick Panthers dick alright let's shift for one second can we talk a little bit about work family balance
我想，这一小筐干花要过多久才会闻起来像一头他妈的黑豹的阴茎？”黑豹的阴茎。好吧，我们暂停一秒钟，我们能聊聊工作与家庭的平衡吗？
are you happier now that I think I don't know much about your career but just from the outside looking at it I'm assuming that the marvel thing is at a slower speed now or or you're done with that now yeah that's all done okay so then I'm
你现在更快乐了吗？我觉得我对你的职业生涯了解不多，但仅从外部来看，我假设漫威的事情现在节奏放慢了，或者你已经不干那个了？对，那些都结束了。好吧，那我就
assuming you're able to spend even more time with the family now are you a more comfortable ratio work family balance sure but quiet as it's kept the last three to five years once you're in a big ensemble where it's like working with Mercury to get everybody in one frame
假设你现在能够花更多的时间陪家人了，你现在的工作与家庭平衡的比例更舒适了吗？当然，但不知为何，过去的三到五年里，一旦你进入一个庞大的演员阵容，就像和水银打交道一样要把所有人凑进一个镜头里，
let alone in the same city for a day out of six weeks I would be at home more often now the big missing integer here is Susan Downey Esquire your wife and really was such a part of the turnaround
更不用说在六周里有一天能聚在同一个城市了，我现在可以在家呆得更多了。这里缺失的重要数字是你的妻子——尊贵的苏珊·唐尼（Susan Downey Esq.），她真的是你人生转折的重要部分，
best mirror and partner for me so we're out here she's up in her office nothing has slowed for the strong of spirit during this time because you can get a lot done remotely just don't have those natural breaks where you get to drive somewhere
是我最好的镜子和伴侣。所以我们在外面，她在楼上她的办公室里。在这个时期，对于精神坚强的人来说，没有任何事情放慢脚步，因为你可以通过远程完成很多工作，只是没有了那些你可以开车去某处、
or hang out in the hallway or stand by the cooler for a minute so I think for a certain type of personality this has been a relentless pride swallowing siege of a time but very productive I am a little bit more the
或者在走廊里闲逛、或者在饮水机旁站一会儿的自然休息时间。所以我认为对于某种性格的人来说，这是一个无情地吞噬自尊的围城般的时期，但非常高产。我稍微更倾向于
I'd like to be of service all day long will they notice when I'm sneaking away to take that hour and seventeen minute nap after I've had a handful of custom colored M&Ms and the other what is that custom color
“我想一整天都为他人服务”这种想法。他们会注意到我溜出去在吃了一把定制颜色的M&M巧克力豆后小睡1小时17分钟吗？还有别的——那是什么定制颜色？
well if you go to Dylan's candy on rain street he has like platinum status at Dylan's candy that's still your not-off-drug sugar so you just mainline on hours worth of sugar and then you sleep it's for the kids baby
嗯，如果你去雷恩街的迪伦糖果店（Dylan's Candy），他就像是迪伦糖果店的白金会员。那依然是你那含糖的非违禁毒品，所以你直接过量摄入了一小时的糖分，然后睡觉。这是为了孩子们，宝贝。
last year Downey came out and he was here with the kids for a couple weeks before Susan got here and it was sugar time went every night till eleven he's like I don't know understand the kids aren't going to sleep and I'm like yeah you're letting them eat Reese's peanut butter and M&Ms until eleven
去年唐尼出来的时候，在苏珊来之前，他带着孩子在这里待了几个星期，那是糖分时间，每天晚上一直玩到11点。他说：“我不明白，孩子们怎么还不睡觉？”我说：“废话，你让他们吃里斯花生酱和M&M巧克力豆一直吃到11点呢。”
so first of all I have bad indulgent instincts but I'm always working on them so it's like I'm always on demerit status so I'm like Avis I'm number two I try harder I'm always trying to make up for when what is the thing that Susan yells at you for giving the kids
所以首先，我有很不好的纵容本能，但我一直在努力改正它们，所以我总是处于记过状态。就像Avis租车公司的广告一样：“我是老二，我更努力。”我总是试图弥补当——苏珊因为你给孩子们吃什么而对你大喊大叫？
uh yeah it would be too much pirate booty or pretzels after they already had a snack or XT once seconds of the ice cream or whatever I'm just like yes yeah I eat ice cream almost every day go ahead right okay particularly lately and you know my
呃，是的，那大概是在他们已经吃过零食或饼干之后，又给他们吃了太多海盗寻宝零食（pirate booty）或者蝴蝶脆饼，或者要求再来一份冰淇淋之类的。我当时就想：对，没错。我几乎每天都吃冰淇淋，接着说吧。没错，特别是最近，你知道的，我的
here's my um here's my four word answer double up your statin calm down about this double up the statin maybe we got this downy yes turn on do people call you Robert or Bob or what do they call you Robert thank you
我的——这是我的四个字的回答：“加倍服用他汀类药物，别为这事大惊小怪，加倍服用他汀类药物，也许我们能搞定这个，唐尼。”对，转身。人们叫你罗伯特还是鲍勃，或者他们叫你什么？罗伯特，谢谢。
so Robert Sean you know why they call that I have no idea what so no I didn't know people called you something for short like a nickname well when they earn it they get it okay so go ahead so anyway DJ
所以，罗伯特，肖恩，你知道他们为什么那么叫吗？我完全不知道。所以，不，我不知道人们会用简称来称呼你，比如昵称。嗯，当他们赢得这个称呼时，他们就得到了。好吧，所以，总之，DJ。
so wait exactly um so to Jason's point earlier about balance of family work and life and all that stuff I always ask other actors this because I fluctuate between that fire in my belly of wanting to prove myself as an actor and stretch my
等一下，嗯，说到杰森刚才提到的关于家庭、工作和生活平衡之类的事，我总是问其他演员这个问题，因为我在那种想证明自己是个演员、想要大展身手的满腔热血之间
you know wings and and you're not talking about your IBS right now right oh we know I was gonna bring that up that's actually where I'm going you're in your belly I want to interrupt your question with a question how many times have you and hubby almost got divorced since you woke up this morning
你知道的，展翅高飞，你现在不是在说你的肠易激综合征吧？哦，我知道，我要提起这个，其实我正要说到这，在你的肚子里，我想用一个问题打断你的问题：自从今天早上醒来以来，你和老公差点离婚多少次了？
before noon uh twice and now we're on the fence we're on the fence we're just making it 14 years we're in mediation it's so true where you're at about 500 since quarantine since lockdown right I'll do this I'll do I said this to the guys I do this it's almost every morning I go like this
在中午之前，呃，两次，现在我们还在观望，还在观望，我们只是过了14年，我们在调解，真的吗？自从隔离以来，自从封城以来，你大概经历了500次吧？我这样做，我这样做，我对伙计们说过，我几乎每天早上都这样
hey Scott do you want to make out uh so yeah like do you still have the fire in your belly to be an actor to like prove yourself to right to that ambition that still drives you do you still have that after all of your success I have an
嘿，斯科特，你想接吻吗？呃，所以，是的，你心里还有那种当演员的热情吗？去证明自己，去拥有那种一直驱动着你的野心？在你取得了所有的成功之后，你还有那种感觉吗？我有
ambition to do things that I've thought I could do well but haven't done before kind of like your boy Bateman has been um and I think like any of us you never you don't want to ever give up a juicy role but the other thing is I'm really good I'm like
一种野心，想去做那些我自认擅长却从未做过的事，有点像你们的贝特曼一直在做的那样，嗯，我觉得就像我们中的任何一个人一样，你永远不会想放弃一个多汁的角色，但另一件事是，我真的很擅长，我像
a first AD I think through this script I've been sent with an offer and I realize you know what this really is 47 days in a tank right 22 days of nights right 15 hours a day it's 18 hours a day
一个第一副导演，我审阅寄给我的带有邀约的剧本，然后我意识到，你知道吗，这其实是在坦克里待47天，对吧？22天的夜戏，对吧？一天15小时，一天18小时
whatever well that I've got that I've got don't be a crazy what are you fighting how dare you insult the guy oh sorry excuse me six hours tops a day next question I love the way you can predict how many nights are in it too you can probably predict there's going to be a lot of base camps that are far
管他呢，好吧，我有这个，我有这个，别犯傻了，你在抗争什么，你怎么敢侮辱这家伙？哦，抱歉，打扰一下，一天最多六小时，下一个问题，我喜欢你连里面有多少场夜戏都能预测的方式，你大概还能预测会有很多大本营离
from set so I'm not going to have the trailer near me okay so this is what I'm saying is all of that yeah here let me answer the question the question is you know are you still feeling it and my thing is I'm never feeling it until I get there when the first clapper goes I wake up
片场很远，所以我不会有房车在我旁边，好吧，这就是我要说的，所有这些，是的，来吧，让我回答这个问题，问题是，你知道，你还有那种感觉吗？而我的情况是，直到我到达现场之前，我从来没有那种感觉，当场记板第一次打响时，我醒了
once the first clapper goes I'm there sure totally but what if it all went away yeah I'm fine okay how about that because because I have a lot of hobbies and I like tweaking on a bunch of stuff name one why are you so angry
一旦场记板一打响，我就进入状态了，当然，完全是这样，但是如果这一切都消失了呢？是的，我很好，好吧，那又怎样？因为因为我有很多爱好，而且我喜欢摆弄各种各样的事，说一个，你为什么这么生气？
Sean Jesus I know no I want to know what they are more than hobbies I have other interests and things that I felt drawn to so to be clear a any actor is a liar if they say how would you feel if it all went away I'd be fine because
肖恩，天哪，我知道，不，我想知道它们是什么，除了爱好，我还有其他的兴趣和让我感到被吸引的事物，所以要明确一点，a，任何一个演员如果说“如果这一切都消失了你会怎么觉得？”“我很好”，那他就是个骗子，因为
well so why yeah nice or actors who announced their retirement I'd like to announce my retirement to make shoes first of all this would be worth it guys I'd be pretty funny if every year show business just retired people yeah I'm sorry this year
好吧，所以为什么，真好，或者那些宣布退休的演员，我想宣布退休去造鞋，首先，这很值得，伙计们，如果每年演艺界都让人们退休，那会挺搞笑的，是的，很抱歉，今年
so and so and so and so have been retired like wait what it's like the premier league you get relegated yeah what would be number one on that hobby list that you'd go to the first day your career went all the way I would dive even deeper into the martial arts and start
某某和某某已经退休了，就像，等等，什么？这就像英超联赛一样，你降级了，是的，在你职业生涯彻底完蛋的第一天，你的爱好名单上的第一名会是什么？我会更深入地钻研武术，开始
opening up some studios are you serious dojo are DJs dojos no no no academies can I tell him dojo is Japanese right yeah he's corrected me on this before so dojo is not what does dojo mean then
开几家武馆，你是认真的吗？道场是道场吗？道场不，不，不，武术馆，我能告诉他道场是日语吗？对，他以前纠正过我这个，所以道场不是，道场是什么意思？
did I fucking stutter that's for dojos for karate and and you're doing wait dojo is for not for kung fu which is what downy does kung fu yeah anyway forget hobbies let's
我是TMD结巴了吗？那是道场，是给空手道用的，而且你在做，等等，道场不是给功夫用的，小唐尼做的是功夫，对吧？不管怎样，忘掉爱好吧，让我们
I want all of us to name another interest so I'll name one but we got to go around okay mine would be technology based climate crisis solutions now you me next
我希望我们每个人都说出另一个兴趣，所以我说一个，但我们得轮流来，好吧，我的会是基于技术的气候危机解决方案，现在，你，我，下一个
more candy commercials mine would be a private jet fund give us a real one come on brother I know you deep mouth yeah I think that sports hockey crap definitely sports hockey stuff but I
更多的糖果广告，我的会是一个私人飞机基金，给我们一个真正的，来吧，兄弟，我懂你的深意，是的，我觉得是体育曲棍球垃圾，绝对是体育曲棍球的东西，但我
think that I don't know I'd probably spend more I'd like to go back to school and study history so would the rest of us like you to do that American history or world history world history European history that's cool I like that
觉得，我不知道，我可能会花更多时间，我想重返校园研究历史，我们其他人也会希望你这么做吗？美国历史还是世界历史？世界历史，欧洲历史，那很酷，我喜欢那个
that's what I spend most of my time reading give it to me Hayes I play piano I've studied piano my whole life and I was going to be a composer and a conductor and all that and then as they say in the business I took a left hand turn and here I am talking to you
那是我花最多时间阅读的内容，交给我吧，海斯，我弹钢琴，我一辈子都在学钢琴，我本来想成为一名作曲家、指挥家之类的，然后，正如行话所说，我向左转，而现在我在这里跟你说话
in the piano business selling them I don't mean playing them no so I I really enjoy that I went away from it for several years and now I've kind of discovered it again so I started playing a lot lately love it Jason what's the thing you would do
在钢琴行业里卖钢琴，我不是指弹钢琴，不，所以我真的很喜欢这个，我离开它好几年了，现在我又重新发现了它，所以我最近开始弹很多，太棒了，杰森，你会做什么？
I would I'm incredibly interested in politics for all the obvious reasons lately and it's not going away it's going larger and larger and larger so I would probably go that direction
我会，出于所有显而易见的原因，我最近对政治产生了极大的兴趣，而且它没有消失，它越来越大，越来越大，所以我可能会朝那个方向发展
Hayes I have a request yes anything Jason and Will know slower my dad I'm doing a documentary about my dad Bob Sr he is hell bent
海斯，我有一个请求，是的，什么都可以，杰森和威尔，慢一点，我爸，我正在制作一部关于我父亲老鲍勃的纪录片，他一门心思
on me recreating this song I sang for the Kiwani solo festival when I was 15 Chuberts Fisherweiser oh yeah it sounds familiar I probably couldn't recall it though
要我重新演绎这首歌，我15岁时在基瓦尼独唱节上唱的那首舒伯特的《渔夫的晚安曲》哦，对，听起来很耳熟，不过我可能想不起来了
what does that mean does that mean you sang a song in German oh boy here we go so he would he wants me to do it as part of the documentary he's hijacked the documentary because
这是什么意思？这意思是你用德语唱了一首歌？哦，天哪，来了来了，所以他希望我把它作为纪录片的一部分，他劫持了这部纪录片，因为
he saw a cut of it and said it's got no rhythm I what we need is some German singing underneath the sequence he's the best he's coming he's coming here next week anyway I brought a pair of laterhosen with me laterhosen literally
他看过初剪版后说这没有节奏，我，我们需要的是在序列下面有一些德语歌唱，他是最棒的，他下周无论如何要来这里，我带了一条皮裤来，皮裤，真的
and I don't know if you have a piano handy but the only way I could do this and record it and film it because I told daddy can hijack the documentary that Chris Smith is actually directing as long as we can film him hijacking the documentary we're doing about his life
我不知道你们有没有现成的钢琴，但这是我能做到这一点的唯一方法，并且把它录下来拍下来，因为我告诉过老爸，克里斯·史密斯实际导演的纪录片可以被他劫持，只要我们能拍下他劫持我们正在拍的关于他一生的纪录片的过程
would you consider accompanying me I don't have to consider of course I would do that thank you that's my get I got my get from Hayes can you get me the music yes no that's the only thing
你考虑为我伴奏吗？我不用考虑，我当然会做，谢谢你，我得到了，我从海斯那里得到了，你能帮我弄到乐谱吗？可以，不，那是唯一的条件
can you get me the music what are you insane I got my last question well you've done a fantastic job of driving this interview today thank you did you come with any questions drive it weren't you supposed to be lobbing bombs from the sideline
你能帮我弄到乐谱吗？你疯了吗？我拿到了我的最后一个问题，好吧，你今天把这次采访主导得太棒了，谢谢你，你带了什么问题来主导吗？你不是应该在场边扔炸弹吗？
but I thought that you guys kept jumping on and saying stuff so I was getting you you know we love so I wanted you to feel that you were free I know I know I mean listen letting it breathe I have a bunch of hard hitting questions I want to ask Robert here we come east side or west side of Manhattan what you
但我以为你们俩一直在插话并说些什么，所以我让你们，你知道，我们爱，所以我希望你觉得你是自由的，我知道，我知道，我的意思是，听着，让它自由呼吸，我有一堆尖锐的问题想问这里的罗伯特，我们来吧，曼哈顿东区还是西区？你
think Upper east Upper east side making a Manhattan that does remind do you have fond memories of your brief stint on Saturday Night Live I have memories I
觉得上东区，上东区，做曼哈顿，这确实让人想起，你对自己在《周六夜现场》的短暂经历有什么美好的回忆吗？我有回忆，我
it was in a what how did that happen how did that process happen that was one of the questions Anthony Michael Hall was cast he said I want my boy to be on the show that's not how it works it's not that's not gonna happen didn't she see weird science Anthony Michael Hall here
是在一个，什么？那是怎么发生的？那个过程是怎么发生的？那是其中一个问题，安东尼·迈克尔·霍尔被选上了，他说我希望我兄弟上这个节目，事情不是这样的，不会这样的，你没看过《奇异科学》吗？安东尼·迈克尔·霍尔在这里
I'm saying my boy down he's on the show let's let's see all right but listen he's great you're gonna love him he'll come audition whatever but then we're gonna need Baluchin Acroids old office and we want bunk beds in there with NFL sheets is that gonna be a problem
我说我兄弟唐尼要上这个节目，我们，我们看看，好吧，但听着，他太棒了，你会喜欢他的，他会来试镜什么的，但我们需要巴鲁奇和阿克罗伊德的旧办公室，我们想要里面有NFL床单的双层床，这会有问题吗？
they're like let's do the audition first and by the way I'll tell you a really fun part we were doing the show and it was the MTV Awards and all I remember is at one point we're in a drop top
他们说，我们先试镜吧，顺便说一句，我告诉你一个特别好玩的部分，我们在做这个节目，那是MTV大奖，我只记得有一点，我们坐在一辆敞篷
DeSoto with a driver with white gloves on I'm sitting with Anthony Michael Hall in the back seat and David Lee Roth is shotgun and we're going somewhere to do something stupid and I said you know what
DeSoto汽车里，司机戴着白手套，我和安东尼·迈克尔·霍尔坐在后座，大卫·李·罗斯坐在副驾驶座上，我们要去某个地方做件蠢事，我说，你知道吗
I'm right where I'm supposed to be where did you go and what did you do where it went gets sadder and sadder and more pathetic and starts opening up some old wounds so let's do it don't go too far but we've talked about Leif Garrett we've talked about on camping trips and stuff with bikes on the top
我就在应该在的地方，你去过哪里，做过什么，事情变得越来越悲伤，越来越可悲，开始揭开一些旧伤疤，所以我们开始吧，别走得太远，但我们谈论过利夫·加雷特，我们谈论过露营旅行之类的事情，自行车架在上面
so they can ride into town and get messy so you can tell a little bit about what happened Downey's probably got some nice Leif stories yeah we had good times with that man should he get Leif on the show I love a bit of Leif Garrett I'll tell you
这样他们就可以骑车进城搞砸一切，所以你可以讲一点发生了什么，唐尼大概有一些关于利夫的好故事，是的，我们和那家伙度过了美好的时光，他应该把利夫请到节目里吗？我挺喜欢利夫·加雷特的，我告诉你
he'd appreciate that do rag your rocket right now yeah right it's got to come down a little lower for Leif yeah bring a little lower just above the eyebrows one serious question and then we can stop with the serious questions when you because when I first
他会感激那个头巾的，你现在戴的那个，对，没错，为了利夫得再往下拉一点，对，再往下拉一点，刚好在眉毛上方，有一个严肃的问题，然后我们就可以停止这些严肃的问题了，当你，因为当我第一次
started learning more about you and your dad and how he was a filmmaker and he was an actor and he brought you on and you guys did drugs as a kid and blah blah blah and then you guys went through all of this journey and you just revealed on this podcast that you're doing a documentary about him how did you come around to forgiving him
开始更多地了解你和你的父亲，他如何成为一名电影制作人，他是一名演员，他把你带进剧组，你们在小时候一起吸毒，巴拉巴拉，然后你们经历了所有这些旅程，你刚刚在这个播客上透露你正在制作一部关于他的纪录片，你是怎么做到原谅他的？
like how did you come back around to having a relationship with somebody who like I'm sure you went through the stages of blaming him and all that stuff because I still blame my dad and I don't know how to get over it but the doc is a hit piece right Downey you have not forgiven him you're gonna drag him
就像，你是如何重新开始与这样一个人的关系的，我确信你经历了责怪他的阶段之类的，因为我仍然责怪我父亲，我不知道该怎么克服它，但这部纪录片是一篇猛烈抨击的文章，对吧，唐尼？你还没有原谅他，你打算把他
across the coals it's a gotcha gorilla style never ending interview and it's you in a frozen wink at the end oh dad you're gonna get this later in laugh well first of all the forgiveness thing
拖进火坑，这是一个“抓到你”式的、游击风格的、永无止境的采访，最后是你冰冷的眨眼，哦，爸爸，你以后会笑着明白这一点的，好吧，首先，原谅这件事
was if you have any empathy it's too hard to stay in that my experience is your fault but I'll tell you something I'll just tell you this story because this is what life is like right my dad
是如果你有任何同理心，停留在那种状态太难了，我的经验是“这是你的错”，但我会告诉你一件事，我只把这个故事告诉你，因为这就是生活本来的样子，对吧？我爸爸
and I decided we were gonna follow George Hamilton around while he was doing a Lecage a faux traveling company sure seems like a plan and we started doing that then my buddy Ashley Hamilton
和我决定我们要跟着乔治·汉密尔顿，当他在一个名为《一笼傻鸟》的法国巡回剧团时，听起来像个计划，我们开始这么做，然后我的哥们阿什利·汉密尔顿
was there and then dad started filming stuff of George and Ashley together and my dad said you know the real story is these two fucking guys right which I thought was father and son I go you're right the father and son story is more interesting than the play
也在那里，然后爸爸开始拍摄乔治和阿什利在一起的东西，我爸爸说，你知道真正的好故事是这两个TMD家伙，对吧？我以为那是父子，我说，你说得对，父子故事比那部戏更有趣
he goes yeah in fact fathers and sons throughout time this is a real that's a subject so for people who don't know the movie bird cage with Nathan Lane and Robin Williams is based on Lecage of all correcto
他说，是的，事实上，古往今来的父子关系，这是一个真正的主题，所以对于不知道由内森·连恩和罗宾·威廉姆斯主演的电影《鸟笼》的人来说，它是基于《一笼傻鸟》改编的，没错
so I say yeah like even fuck you Sean fuck you we're done so I say to senior I go yeah like even you and me that's a story he goes yeah it's a story anyway and then he says
所以我说，是的，甚至去你的，肖恩，去你的，我们完了，所以我对老头子说，我觉得甚至你和我，那也是个故事，他说，是的，是个故事，无论如何，然后他说
you know what the real interesting story is and then he told me about this other father and son Sean Flynn who was Errol Flynn's son actually did all the stuff that his dad did in the movies he was in going into Cambodia or crossing the Laotian border he was a photojournalist a real
你知道真正有趣的故事是什么吗，然后他告诉我另一个父子故事，肖恩·弗林，埃罗尔·弗林的儿子，他实际上做了他父亲在电影里做的所有事情，他去了柬埔寨或穿过老挝边境，他是一名战地摄影记者，一个真正的
adventurer and then he got lost and probably taken prisoner and probably executed and I was like wow and so then he started sending me like bit real some what he thought the documentary that had nothing now to do with Ashley and George
冒险家，然后他失踪了，可能被俘虏了，可能被处决了，我当时想，哇，然后他开始给我发一些花絮素材，关于他认为的、现在与阿什利和乔治无关的纪录片
about Sean and Errol the Flynn's and I'm like what is he driving and I said so I thought maybe I could trick him into me doing a documentary about him while he thinks we're doing a documentary about other fathers and sons and then
关于肖恩和埃罗尔·弗林父子的，我在想，他在搞什么名堂？我说，所以我以为我可以骗他，让我来拍一部关于他的纪录片，而他以为我们在拍一部关于其他父子的纪录片，然后
I got busy and went and did a couple movies and then came back and Chris Smith who's arguably the greatest documentary maker around right now one of the top guys he started getting into it and I said I really like this and he liked it even more when
我变得很忙，去拍了几部电影，然后回来了，克里斯·史密斯——可以说现在是周围最伟大的纪录片制作人之一，顶级人物之一——开始参与进来了，我说我真的很喜欢这个，当
my dad started saying I'm gonna show this clown how to make a doc or whatever because he's like I love it because your dad only cares about the moment and just because the documentary is about him doesn't mean it isn't a project and so if we're gonna do a project let's do something
我爸开始说“我要给这个小丑示范一下怎么拍纪录片”或者别的什么时，他更喜欢了，因为他就像，我喜欢这样，因为你爸只关心当下，而且纪录片关于他并不意味着它就不是一个项目，所以既然我们要搞一个项目，那就做点
he goes documentary so boring everyone is just sitting there talking he should be walking around and so all of a sudden we're shooting stuff like people talking about my dad by a duck pond and he's like cut back three weeks later when the ducks are big and then like the screen says three weeks later and the ducks
他觉得纪录片太无聊了，每个人都只是坐在那儿聊天，他应该四处走走，所以突然之间我们在拍一些东西，比如人们在鸭塘边谈论我爸，他说“切到三周后，当鸭子变大的时候”，然后屏幕上显示“三周后，鸭子
are big or we're sitting at a table and I'm like you know dad I just really want to save when we're going through all that stuff he goes look at the cane the cane's got a lizard head going tight on the lizard head and I'm just like I fucking love him so much
变大了”，或者我们坐在桌子旁，我说，“你知道，爸爸，当我们经历所有这些事情时，我真的想拯救”，他说，“看手杖，手杖有个蜥蜴头，特写蜥蜴头”，我当时就想，我太TMD爱他了
he is a true artist so my misses who I thought would be super skeptical because this is not cheap she watches the first cut she goes you know what I understand your dad now I can't wait I can't wait to see this it'll be pretty great I can't wait Sean you're in it you're part of the
他是个真正的艺术家，所以我的太太——我以为她会超级怀疑，因为这并不便宜——看了初剪版后说，“你知道吗，我现在理解你爸爸了，我等不及了，我等不及要看这个了，这会相当棒的”，我等不及了，肖恩，你在里面，你是
you're literally in it so Robert is there a camera shooting the camera that's shooting the documentary is there oh that's great when do we get to see this well how close are you to Doug well he's coming out next week he says we got about six or eight days of shooting left
你真的是在里面，所以，罗伯特，有没有一个摄像机在拍那个正在拍纪录片的摄像机？有吗？那太棒了，我们什么时候能看到这个？好吧，你离杀青还有多近？好吧，他下周要来，他说我们大概还有六到八天的拍摄时间
I was like well hold on a minute now what does Chris Smith say Chris says we need two different budgets the budget for the movie I'm doing about your dad and the budget for the movie your dad is doing based on the fact that he doesn't think my movie is any good even though it's a documentary
我当时就想，等等，克里斯·史密斯是怎么说的？克里斯说我们需要两个不同的预算：一个是拍你爸爸的那部电影的预算，另一个是你爸爸根据他觉得我的电影不怎么样（尽管这是一部纪录片）而要拍的电影的预算。
that's a way so let me ask you something Robert has the has the shift happened yet where the son now becomes the parent um look I let's just agree that the meditation
就是这样，所以我问你个问题，罗伯特，那个转变已经发生了吗？就是儿子现在变成了老子，嗯，听着，我们承认吧，那个冥想
on one's closest family associates in this case the father son relationship it is I don't even know part of the reason that I keep this is so numinous look it up to me is because I feel
对于自己最亲近的家庭成员，在这种情况下是父子关系，我甚至不知道，我保留这个的部分原因是因为它充满神秘色彩，去查查看，对我来说是因为我觉得
drawn to figuring out all this stuff that is entirely unconscious that I won't really figure out like I said earlier you know it's like two weeks later you realize what you would have said this is going to be like years from now I'll probably have a smidge of an understanding
被弄清楚所有这些完全无意识的事情所吸引，就像我刚才说的，我真的无法弄清楚，你知道的，就像两周后你才意识到你当时应该说什么，这大概要过好几年我才会有一点点理解
about what it all meant and I also know that he's leaving breadcrumbs I know it I know that intuitively he is doing part of this to leave some sort of incomprehensible perfect messaging to me
关于这一切意味着什么，而且我也知道他在留下蛛丝马迹，我知道，我直觉地知道他这样做的一部分原因是为了给我留下某种无法理解的完美信息。
or at least that's what I'm expecting you know on that it's something I've I bet we've all been thinking about because we're all roughly the same age how much Robert do you think and thinking about your dad and looking like that is that's the tree I am the acorn
或者至少我是这么期望的，你知道的，这肯定是大家都在想的事情，因为我们年龄都差不多，罗伯特，你觉得考虑到你父亲以及长相，这就是“有其父必有其子”吧
how much do you think you're going to change between now and the end of your life or do you think and I throw this out to you guys too do you think that there's like a lot of changing obviously when we're teenagers and whatnot but like once you become a certain age I feel like the moves are
你觉得从现在到你生命的尽头，你会有多大改变？或者说——我也把这个问题抛给你们——你们觉得，当然我们在青少年时期等等会有很多改变，但一旦到了某个年龄，我感觉这些变化就会……
not that big anymore or maybe they are how much how much big how many more big moves do you think you're going to be making I stopped growing at 17 years old yeah yeah pretty much the same sense I would agree with that yeah you're not going to hear anything out of me yeah
已经没那么大了，或者说也许它们就是。你觉得你还会做出多少次更大的变动？我17岁就停止长高了。对，差不多也是这种感觉，我同意这一点。是的，你从我这里什么也听不到，是的。
I don't need to hear anything I was being kind taking it to both you guys Robert yes here yes please the growth it depends on what happens so any time I've grown it's been either the things were too painful to not change
我不需要听任何废话，我对你们两个客气才拿出来讨论的。罗伯特，是的，这儿，请吧。成长取决于接下来发生的事，所以无论我什么时候成长，要么是因为事情太痛苦而不得不改变
or I was confronted with something that if I didn't adapt I was going to perish so it could be illness it could be but I always leave open the possibility of some great new inspiration I totally believe that we're following this
或者我面临着这样一种情况：如果我不适应，我就会毁灭，所以它可能是疾病，也可能是……但我总是对获得某种伟大的新灵感持开放态度，我完全相信我们正在追随这一点
little golden thread of things where I mean how did the four of us wind up here today how many things had to go right for this I think about that stuff all the time but do you have anything sort of and I'm not asking you to say what it is but is there something that you kind
一条由事物组成的小小金色线索，我是说，我们四个今天怎么会聚在这里？为此有多少事情必须顺利发展？我一直都在思考这些事情，但是你有没有某种——我不是让你说它是什么——但有没有某种
of have earmarked that this is this is one thing I'd like to change before I'm done or are you pretty content you strike me as some it's okay to say that you're not going to be calling yourself perfect but like I would I wouldn't be surprised if you said that you were content you seem to have really put the work in
有没有什么事是你已经列出来，觉得这是我离开之前想改变的一点，还是说你其实挺满足的？你给我的感觉是——你可以说你觉得自己并不完美，但我如果听到你说你很满足，我也不会感到惊讶，你似乎真的付出了很多努力。
look I mean you know 70% maintenance I want to head in the direction that you have so expertly gone I want to write and direct even though it just sounds like the worst worst job in the world but I think I have to
听着，我的意思是，你知道的，70%的精力都在维护，我想朝着你那么专业地走过的方向前进，我想写作和导演，尽管听起来这简直是世界上最糟糕、最糟糕的工作，但我想我必须这么做
even if I just do it once like Don Cheadle directed one of my favorite movies in the last five years Miles Head he plays Miles Davis and you and McGregor plays this guy is trying to get an interview and all Miles wants to do is go get the cope that this guy owes him and it's but they learn
即使我只做过一次，就像唐·钱德尔导演了我过去五年中最喜欢的电影之一《迈尔斯·戴维斯》，他饰演迈尔斯·戴维斯，而伊万·麦格雷戈饰演这个试图进行采访的家伙，迈尔斯只想去拿这个家伙欠他的可卡因，但是他们了解到了
a lot about each other and it's beautiful he's he don't you know is amazing okay and I was like don do what did it feel like because you I mean the role in the thing goes hated it is like why he goes terrible what no directing part just the short
彼此了解了很多，这很美好，他真的很棒，好吧，然后我就问，感觉怎么样？因为我的意思是，那个角色……他说讨厌，我就问为什么，他说太糟糕了，什么？不是导演部分，只是那个短片
shooting schedule the budget the billion decisions you know because like on set we're shooting like you know whatever you know roadie and Tony and like between takes he's like playing cards and talking smack and it's just like it's it's the easiest job
拍摄日程、预算、成千上万的决定，你知道的，因为在片场我们拍摄时，你知道的，罗迪（Roadie）和托尼（Tony），在拍片间隙他就在玩牌、说垃圾话，这简直就是最轻松的工作。
in the world he's like rolling off a log they are such a natural and then that is nothing you're answering 30,000 questions a day that people should be walking over to you to tell you that they have an answer you first of all you've got obviously got the capacity for it I need you don't need me to tell you that and you are really an artist
在世界上他就像砍瓜切菜一样自然，然后那根本不算什么，你每天要回答三万个本该由别人走过来告诉你答案的问题，首先你显然有这个能力，你不需要我来告诉你这一点，而且你真的是个艺术家
and you do have a real understanding and that is grown kind of to what Jason you were saying your your perspective has changed in the last 10 years certainly in the last 20 years right I mean a lot and the discipline that that that you have
而且你确实有着真正的理解，正如你所说的，杰森，在过去10年里，当然还有过去20年里，你的观点确实发生了变化，对吧？我的意思是，变化很大，而且你所拥有的那种自律也是。
is is cannot be underestimated sure but well certainly you have a lot of discipline but also like you're just your desire to artistically express yourself at any given moment is constantly there it's right beneath the surface
这是绝对不能低估的，当然，你的自律性确实很强，但同时也像这样，你在任何时刻都有艺术表达的强烈愿望，这种愿望一直都在，就在水面之下。
or it's on the surface or it's out there right I mean that's something you're always kind of doing and and I mean that as a compliment and I can't imagine that that would be so such a difficult thing for you to do to to write and direct do you think the writing would be more difficult
或者就在表面上，或者就在那里，对吧？我的意思是，这是你一直在做的事情，我是作为赞美这样说的，我无法想象这对于你来说是一件多么困难的事，去写作和导演，你觉得写作会更困难吗？
than the directing or vice versa the writing I think any of anyone who's been even near a good writer you see that they just get lifted up into this space where they're really just channeling the best connective ideas that are out there somewhere somehow
比导演工作更重要，或者反过来，写作也是如此。我认为任何接触过优秀作家的人都会发现，他们被提升到了这样一个境界：他们实际上只是在传达那些不知从哪里、以某种方式存在的最佳连结思想。
you know some people are really good nuts and bolts writers but I mean it's just the best dude my dad says this anybody can act few can direct nobody can write so if you're a writer by
你知道的，有些人真的很擅长写细枝末节的文字，但我的意思是，这真的是最棒的，老兄。我爸爸说过这句话：谁都能表演，少数人能导演，没人能写作。所以如果你是一个作家，凭借着
his estimation you are top of the food chain funny actually another guy who wrote that Jesus God help us that probably takes us to a commercial I bet yeah yeah no but to all that and I go on and on almost every episode
据他估计你是食物链顶端的人，真搞笑，实际上另一个写了这话的人是——耶稣，上帝帮帮我们，这大概要进广告了吧，我敢说，是啊，是啊，不过对于这一切，我几乎在每一集里都会说个没完
you do you sure do anyway thanks Robert hold on give my man I go on and on about how brilliant Jason Bateman is wait when and Ozark oh I'm so far up his ass I'm gonna leave him Scotty for him let him finish guys but I always ask you Jason too
随你便，你当然可以，不管怎样，谢谢罗伯特，等等，让我的人继续说，我一直在滔滔不绝地称赞杰森·贝特曼有多才华横溢，等等，什么时候演的《黑钱胜地》？哦，我太崇拜他了，我都快成他肚里的蛔虫了，让他说完吧各位，不过我总是问你，杰森...
I was thinking about this I guess I haven't asked we've been talking to Robert about this I don't know how you can divide your brain into conceiving the direction of a scene and then shelving that and going in front of the camera and acting it just seems like so much overload on the brain
我在想这个，我想我还没问过，我们一直在和罗伯特谈论这个，我不知道你怎么能把你的大脑分成两部分：一方面构思场景的方向，另一方面把它搁置一边，走到镜头前去表演，这简直是对大脑的超负荷运转。
I don't know how you do it and you do it so brilliantly honest quick answer is that you do all the directing and then when it's time to act you just do the acting so like between hang on I gotta write this down so you just direct and then you act yeah between action and cut
我不知道你是怎么做到的，而且你做得如此出色。老实说，简短的回答是，你负责所有的导演工作，然后在该表演的时候，你就只管表演。所以，在……等一下，我得把它记下来，所以你先导演，然后表演？是的，在“开始”和“停”之间。
number two is act is that right yeah between action and cut it's the acting everything else is the directing Sean what do you like that I do go ahead take your time take your time I like you in hats more than your hair thanks man I'll take it okay guys
第二点是行动，对吧，是的，在“开始”和“停”之间就是表演，其余的都是导演，肖恩，你喜欢我做什么，来吧，慢慢来，慢慢来，比起你的头发，我更喜欢你戴帽子的样子，谢啦兄弟，我接受了，好了，伙计们
I always tell Will he's the funniest person alive no no no I'll second I'll tell you this he's the person on earth that I have ever met who enjoys being himself the most and it's infectious yeah nobody but I found that that Will laughs the
我总是告诉威尔，他是活着的最好笑的人。不，不，不，我附议，我跟你说，他是我见过的地球上最喜欢做自己的人，而且很有感染力。是的，没有人，但我发现威尔笑得
hardest at nobody but himself that's self love we're all looking for it I actually I don't think I've ever met a person that doesn't love every second they spend with Will or not yeah that is that is true it's true
对自己要求最严格的只有他自己，那是自爱，我们都在寻找自爱，实际上，我想我从没见过哪个人不享受和威尔在一起的每一秒，不是吗，是的，这是真的，确实如此
come on maybe they know how close we are so they they don't they don't talk to me how much they hate you yeah coming up to me on the street going I just don't like them I just get it I'm not a fan yeah not for me not for me I don't get it this is a great Hollywood like hey what do you think of
得了吧，也许他们知道我们关系有多好，所以他们不肯，他们不肯当着我的面说他们有多讨厌你。对啊，在大街上走到我面前说，我就是不喜欢他们，我就是get不到，我不是粉丝，对啊，不适合我，不适合我，我get不到。这才是地道的荷里活风格，就像是，嘿，你觉得怎么样
the the movie nobody wants to have an opinion in case they're wrong or they'll lose their job over it so it's like what do you think of the thing um wasn't for me I mean I don't get it but I definitely see how people so you didn't like it how great how great was it
这部电影没有人敢发表意见，生怕自己说错或者因此失去工作，所以就像是——“你觉得这东西怎么样？”“嗯，不太适合我，我是说我不太懂，但我绝对能理解为什么有人会……”“所以你不喜欢它？”“太棒了，这有多棒啊！”
having down here to my gosh leave it what a luck out incredible I know Robert thank you thank you thank you thank you please say hi to Susan I will thank you most of all you're my new friend I know these other guys pretty well Robert I adore you
能来到这里，天哪，真是太走运了，难以置信。我知道，罗伯特，谢谢你，谢谢你，谢谢你，谢谢你。请代我向苏珊问好。我会的。最重要的是，你是我的新朋友。我对其他几个人挺熟的，罗伯特，我崇拜你。
I truly do I am a huge fan of yours in business and now I'm a huge fan of yours in life for real and I just love you likewise thank you and I also love your business oh god fuck I said it wrong
我是认真的，我在商业上是你的超级粉丝，现在我在生活中也是你的超级粉丝，真的，我只是爱你，彼此彼此，谢谢你，我也爱你的生意，哦天哪，操，我说错了
now get in the car thank you for coming and doing this that was a great episode right having having Downey incredible love him thank you no we gotta pretend you're not here we'd be how great was that right he was amazing I'm unbelievable nice going you know what we can't pretend that Downey's not here this is the first time we're ever doing the goodbye with the guest
现在上车，谢谢你来参加节目，这期节目太棒了，对吧？有小罗伯特·唐尼在，太不可思议了，爱死他了，谢谢，不，我们得假装你不在，我们要——多棒啊，对吧？他太棒了，难以置信，干得好，你知道吗？我们不能假装唐尼不在，这是我们第一次在有嘉宾的情况下说再见。
in the house that's right just be one of the people saying how great it was witnessing his own funeral how great was it having Downey today oh my he nailed it well he's still here I mean it's all downhill from here oh my god the ratings look at the spike do you think so
在演播室里，没错，就做那种看着自己的葬礼并感叹它有多棒的人。小罗伯特·唐尼今天表现得太棒了，天哪，他简直绝了。不过他还在呢，我是说，从这以后就走下坡路了。天哪，收视率，快看这飙升的势头，你觉得呢？
I can't wait I'm making a documentary about him making a documentary about his dad is making a documentary about his own life and Jason I wanted to ask you will you do wardrobe on it Brett had bands for everybody that was so fun I just want to say because I want to be the first to say bye
我等不及了，我在拍一部关于他拍一部关于他爸爸拍一部关于他自己人生的纪录片的纪录片，杰森我想问你，你愿意为它设计服装吗？布雷特给每个人都准备了乐队，那太有趣了，我只想说，因为我想成为第一个说再见的人
bye smart smart smart smart There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见 聪明 聪明 聪明 聪明 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。